so John McCrae AKA what do you meme was
making a video about what led
billionaire rapper songwriter
entrepreneur and theologian Jay-Z to
initially question Christianity and John
found a clip of Jay-Z claiming that God
is the same in the Bible and the Quran
and he asked me if I could respond to
that claim now you may be wondering how
can we seriously question a man who
convinced Beyonce to marry him I mean
how could this guy be wrong about
anything but it's just a fact of life
that people who are brilliant and
successful in one area can be totally
clueless in other areas what can I say
it's a hard knock life if you're not
familiar with Jay-Z the man is very
intelligent in the clip John sent me
Jay-Z talks about why he believes in God
and it's clear that he's thought a lot
about design in nature I don't know how
else to explain this Sunset and how if I
get a cut you know a scab form and how
my body is like this uh computer that
reacts to movement how my eyebrows is uh
made to keep sweat from going in my eyes
and how everything works so
perfectly no one can tell me that two
planets crashed and these things
happened it's very hard for me to
believe that so he's thought a lot about
why he believes in God but like so many
other entertainers caught up in all
these lights and cameras he crosses over
into some other areas where he just
doesn't know what he's talking about I
think you know uh people that are
reading the Quran and people that are
reading the Bible are really reading
about the same person Christians and
Muslims agree on a number of issues we
agree that there's one God all powerful
all knowing and merciful we agree that
God has revealed messages through
prophets we agree that Jes Jesus was
born of a virgin that he performed
Miracles and that he's the
Messiah so we're obviously talking about
the same God right no there are
similarities because Muhammad was to
plagiarism what Jay-Z is to Rap Only
Muhammad didn't get Beyonce he got Aisha
his six-year-old child bride the
similarities between Christianity and
Islam upon closer inspection turn out to
be superficial the remnants of
Muhammad's addiction to
plagiarism the theological differences
between Islam and Christianity are
crucial and these theological
differences have consequences in ethics
let me give you an
example in both the Old and New
Testaments Jews and Christians refer to
God as father Our Father in Heaven the
Quran repeatedly declares that Allah is
a father to no one he's not a father in
any sense this is why you don't hear
Muslims calling god father Allah's got
99 names but father ain't one now this
may seem like a small matter but it's
actually extremely
important if God is our heavenly father
then we are children of God the Bible
says that even pagans are children of
God but we can also be children of God
in a higher sense by contrast the
highest relationship you can have with
Allah who is a father to no one is a
slave to master relationship according
to the Quran all you are all you ever
have been all you ever will be to Allah
is a
slave think about the implications here
parents love their children
automatically unless they're just
massively defective parents when parents
have a child they don't say hey let's
wait until she grows up and then we'll
see if she's a good daughter or a bad
daughter and then we'll decide whether
to love her or not parents love their
child from the beginning a slave master
doesn't automatically love his slave he
might eventually come to love his slave
for being a really good slave but he
won't love a bad slave and so we read
the Quran and we find out that Allah has
no love for his bad slaves Allah does
not love those who exceed the limits
Allah does not love any ungrateful
sinner Allah does not love the
unbelievers Allah does not love the
unjust Allah does not love him who is
proud boastful Allah does not love the
extravagant Allah does not love the
treacherous Allah does not love the
Mischief Makers Allah does not love any
arrogant
boaster you're nothing more than a slave
to Allah so if you want Allah to love
you you have to earn Allah's Love by
being a good Slave how does this view of
what we are affect how we treat our
fellow human beings should a good slave
who spends all his time serving his
master have any love for a bad slave who
ignores his master Surah 58: 22 of the
Quran thou Wilt not find any people who
believe in God and the last day loving
those who resist God and His Apostle
even though they were their fathers or
their sons or their brothers or their
Kindred notice you shouldn't even love
your own family members if they resist
Allah and
Muhammad what would Jesus think about
this well we don't have to wonder
Matthew 5:
43-48 you have heard that it was said
You shall love your neighbor and hate
your enemy wow sounds exactly like what
Allah says in the Quran but I say to you
love your enemies and pray for those who
persecute you but why Jesus so that you
may be sons of your father who is in
heaven for he makes his son rise on the
evil and on the good and sends reain on
the just and on the unjust for if you
love those who love you what reward do
you have do not even the tax collectors
do the same and if you greet only your
brothers what more are you doing than
others do not even the Gentiles do the
same you therefore must be perfect as
your heavenly father is perfect why do
we love our enemies because our heavenly
father loves them Jesus says if you only
love people who love you what are you
doing even Tax Collectors do that keep
in mind that the tax collectors he was
referring to were worse than the tax
collectors we're familiar with he was
referring to Jewish tax Tax Collectors
who collected taxes for the Roman Empire
but they would charge extra to make
themselves Rich they were viewed as
Traders by other Jews Jesus says to his
listeners even those people who are
raising your taxes to make themselves
Rich love people who love them first
don't you want to be better than that
but the self-serving love that Jesus
condemns is exactly the sort of Love
That Allah has in the Quran Allah only
loves you if you believe in him and love
him and Obey him first
he has no love for those who don't
believe in him or love him or obey him
and he doesn't want his followers to
love those who don't believe in him or
love him or obey him you love Allah
first and then he'll love you back and
when he loves you back he'll tell his
followers to treat you better than they
were treating you
before this is very different from the
Bible which says in 1 John 4:19 that we
love because he first loved us God loved
us
before we ever loved him why he's our
father we're his children and not only
did he love us before we ever loved him
he saved us when we were powerless
ungodly Sinners Romans 56 through 8 the
Apostle Paul writes you see at just the
right time when we were still powerless
Christ died for the ungodly very rarely
will anyone die for a righteous person
though for a good person someone might
might possibly dare to die but God
demonstrates his own love for us in this
while we were still sinners Christ died
for us are people who read the Bible and
the Quran reading about the same God of
course not one is a counterfeit why are
there similarities because the job of a
counterfeit is to make something that
looks enough like the original to
deceive as many people as possible now
we've only scratched the surface here
there are all kinds of ways the god of
the Bible is different from the god of
the Quran the god of the Bible is Triune
the god of the Quran isn't the god of
the Bible and the god of the Quran have
different attributes they created human
beings for very different reasons they
want human beings to behave in very
different ways there are a million and
one questions we could bring up and
endless videos we could make but I'm in
an Empire State state of mind and I want
to discuss what initially LED Jay-Z to
doubt Christianity turns out that Jay-Z
had an emotional reaction to hypocrisy
in the church as you know when it comes
to discussing people's emotional
reactions there's no one better than
your boy DW because I all right sorry
guys I hate to interrupt but this next
part requires some emotionally sensitive
navigation and as you probably already
know emotional sensitivity isn't a
psychopath's strongest suit so I thought
I'd help out go ahead and click here to
hear the reasons why Jay-Z rejects
Christianity and we'll see you over
there in five 4 3 two